Good morning, everyone. It is 10:00 on
Tuesday, May 17. Welcome.
This is a continuation of the Budget and Fiscal Affairs Committee meetings and
budget presentations from various departments in the city of Houston. I'll call
this meeting to order and like to welcome all council members in attendance.
Council Member Tasha Jackson district B council Member Abby
Cayman district C council Member Tiffany vice
Chair Edward J. Pollard District J staff
from Council member Michael Kubosh's office michael Knox martha Castex
tatum carlos Cisneros and
Amy Peck and Tiffany Thomas thank you.
And staff from Council Member Alcorn's office and plumber.
All budget workshops would be conducted in person. Only public speakers have
the option to comment in person or virtually 48
hours prior to the start of all workshops. All presentation materials are
uploaded to SharePoint and hard copies are delivered
to each council office. All departments have been directed to provide written
responses within 48 hours of the conclusion of their presentation
to any questions posted by council members to SharePoint
budget workshop is scheduled. Schedule is posted on
the BFA website. Questions from council members can be
uploaded at any time during the budget workshop process,
the earlier the better, allowing the departments plenty of time to
respond to questions. All public speakers should
be signed up to speak. If you have not signed up,
please sign up at the front table facing our left.
Your right. Budget 23
template has been uploaded to SharePoint. And Mayor Turner,
as we know, sent out a memo to all council members and offices to
ensure productive discussions on the proposed budget. And all
amendments are due Wednesday, May 25.
Today we'll hear from General Services Department.
Promptly on time, as always. Parks and Recreation and
the Houston Police Department. As a reminder,
only people attending virtually are the public speakers. We'll get to their questions
after the presentations and after questions from council
members have concluded. At this time, I would like
to welcome Director CJ Messiah and Mr. Russell Lee to provide
the General Services Department budget. Thank you
and welcome. And I see you have your department members with us.
You all do a great job day in and day out, so thank you for
what you do. Except you, Eric.
That's my man.
All right.
Can you hear me? All right. There it is. Good morning and thank
you for the opportunity to present the fiscal year 2023 budget for
the General Services Department. I have three principles that I share
with our GSD team, and that's integrity. First, service before
self and excellence in all we do.
With me today is my senior staff, which includes Chief of
Staff Enid Howard. Assistant Director of
Design and Construction and Real Estate, Richard Veylor.
Assistant Director of Property Management, Eric Alexander.
Deputy Assistant Director of Security Management, Robert Mansaw.
Our training division manager, Darnisha Davis Collier
my Executive assistant, Levanda Donohue senior
Staff Analyst, Shelley Carter, who manages the energy Resilience
and efficiency program and to my right, a Chief Financial
Officer and Division Manager, Russell Lee, who will be assisting me in answering
any financial questions regarding the fiscal year 23 proposed
budget. Next slide.
GSD operations are divided into four core programs of
service one, property and environmental management two,
design and construction and real estate services three
security management and four, administrative,
financial and energy management services with the primary goals
of reducing costs and continuing to improve our level of customer service.
Our current organizational structure shows our total
operating budget for the General Fund to be just over $42.1
million with 154 FTEs.
Next slide.
The project cost recovery fund has a proposed budget of
$6.8 million with 51 FTEs.
All expenses in this fund are charged back to the Capital Improvement Plan
or CIP, Bond funds. The FTEs in this fund provide
CIP planning, management, manage the design
and construction facilities for all departments except
the Houston Airport System, manage the CIP construction
contracts, and facilitate tenant moves and improvements.
By mid September this year, we will be complete with the A leaf
neighborhood center and the maintenance and operational costs are included
in our FY 2023 proposed budget.
Next slide.
The Maintenance, Renewal and Replacement, or MRR
fund has a proposed budget of $30.77
million and 76 FTEs. This fund provides
for the maintenance, repair and replacement of building systems and operational
components for mechanical, electrical, plumbing,
HVAC, life, safety, security, monitoring,
structural and energy systems.
Next,
in our General Fund revenue budget, there's an increase of
$29,000 due to an escalations on rents
that GSD collects and an increase of $19,000
due to an increase in planned projects that will be charged back to the
Fleet Department and Parking Management. General Services will
continue to charge back its personnel costs for operations of public works
facilities. There is a decrease in miscellaneous
revenue as we do not budget for possible recoveries and
refunds. Next.
Our General Fund revenue is budgeted at 3.9 million
with changes as discussed in the previous slide. Our Project
Recovery Fund revenue is budgeted at just under $6.8
million, an increase of $1.6 million
due to the hiring of additional project managers and support personnel.
During fiscal year 22, our in house renovation
group budget was decreased to zero due to this group being dissolved
and FTEs being moved to the General Fund or MRR.
Fund. Our MRR revenue is budgeted
at $29.8 million, which is the same as the FY
22 adopted budget. The increase
over fiscal year 21 is primarily due to finance
reducing the revenue transferred into the Fund in FY
21 to assist with the FY 21 budget
deficit. Next slide.
For FY 23, we are proposing an expenditure budget
in our General Fund of $42.2 million.
The restricted accounts include service chargeback accounts for items
such as fuel, electricity, It accounts,
et cetera. Next slide.
The total proposed budget for all funds for fiscal year 2023
is $79.6 million. Next slide.
In the General Fund, the $28.3 million nonpersonal
costs make up roughly 67% of the General Fund
budget. Restricted accounts represent roughly
38% of the total nonpersonal costs.
The remaining nonpersonal budget is for services such as janitorial
services, security management, sewer services,
real estate rentals and landscaping.
Next, the Project Cost Recovery
Fund personnel costs make up 97% of
the budget, with restricted accounts and miscellaneous
services making up the remaining 3%.
Next,
in the MRR Fund, the $23.7
million in nonpersonal costs make up 77.2%
of the budget. Of this, $21.2 million,
or 89.6% is budgeted
for services and $2.4 million, or 10.4%,
is budgeted for supplies. Next.
GSD's fiscal year 22 adopted budget was $41.9
million. With the fiscal year 2022 budget adjustments,
our projected current General Fund budget
is now $41.6 million. In the
General Fund, we are proposing an FY 2023 expenditure budget
of $42.1 million. As noted on the
exhibit, this includes the adjustments for the opening of
the A Leaf Neighborhood Center and contractual and operational
adjustments. Next,
this graph shows the previous five years budgets compared
to our proposed FY 23 budget. The increase
in the budget from FY 22 to 23 is due
to the 3% Hope increase, as well as the additional budget
for operational and maintenance of the new A Leaf Neighborhood
Center. This concludes our presentations. Do you
have any questions, sir? We sure
do, and thanks for the presentation. We'll start off with council member Abby Cayman.
Good morning, Director, and thank you again to you and your entire team.
You all are often behind the scenes, but we can't get anything done if we
don't have the structural integrity to do so.
So thank you all. Director, three quick
questions for you. One, can you provide a quick update to
us? I know we're getting going
on construction for the annex tunnel, things like that, but damages sustained
during Harvey. Where are we in that recovery process
for our buildings right now? And I'll speak first on City
Hall and City Hall annex, which you see every day. And you've
seen some significant improvement in the City Hall basement.
So I'll start with the tunnel. So the tunnel, if you've
noticed, on the Bagby Street side, there's a lot of digging and corriding to
find the source of the water intrusion into the tunnel.
Once we find that and the tunnel is sealed to
keep the water from intruding, that part of
the Harvey damage will start to be done
at City Hall. We're waiting for a
call today from the ceiling tile contractor, and we're keeping our fingers
crossed. As with everything in the nation,
COVID and the war in Ukraine has put a damper on receiving
materials. We were initially told the ceiling tiles for
the hallway and the mayor's conference room would be about
a twelve to 16 week lead time.
The contractor is waiting on a call. We believe we got that down to three
or four weeks. If that is true, we will be complete with the
basement by the end of June.
Kindle library is another. It's on track
to be finished sometime soon. So we're making
progress. But, again, we did run into delays
with COVID and then the war in Ukraine. No,
and I bring that up especially for the purposes for public knowledge
in terms of we're still working on everything from Harvey, and it's
been slow with Ukraine. And I know you all are working as quickly as possible,
but even on city properties, we're still
dealing with addressing a lot of those challenges. Right. And we look
at municipal courts. We are dealing with well,
not our office, but Finance and Mr.
Costello's group are dealing with FEMA for the funding
to replace municipal courts. And it's five
years later. Back in queue, please.
So you're getting off easy. There are no other questions from council members,
but I would like to state yeah, go ahead.
No one else is in queue. Okay.
Secondly director asking.
I got two more questions. Second Director,
you and your chief of staff and your entire staff,
I know, worked really diligently when an issue came up. And I was hoping you
could share with us the progress
that has been made in terms of healthcare coverage for our security personnel
and just all of the efforts that you and your team made
to make sure that we're doing right by our security personnel.
Sure. And if I can, I'll tell a little story on how this
came about. So, Council Member Cayman,
who talks to the security officers here on a daily basis,
noticed the security officer with a limp, and they talked
about going to see a doctor. And the security officer told
them that she didn't have medical insurance because it was too
high. So the council member contacted my office, and we looked into
it, and we found a huge discrepancy with
the contractor as far as meeting the requirements for
payer play, and the contractor is good.
They met with us, we discussed the discrepancy.
And that was all started in December by
I think it was end of February or March. We had 199
security officers on the contract working here
at City Hall and City Hall Annex. Of that
199, only 33 of them were verified
to have any type of insurance coverage. With the help
of the insurance company and us getting them within compliance,
they moved that up totally with their insurance or
any other type of insurance, up to 162.
So we thank you for bringing it to us,
because it also discovered some discrepancies. We have
not only GSD, but dealings with SPD and Oboe
on maintaining the compliance of Pay or
Play, which we're working with those other departments to make sure the contractors
are within compliance. I appreciate that
update. And again, I credit you and your team for
all of the work that was done on that. I simply asked a question.
But the credit lies with you all and bringing them up finally, Director,
I'm asking every department, due to the financial constraints that
not only Council is facing, but the city as a whole is facing,
what are the needs that are not currently being
met by this budget and what are the foreseeable needs
in the near future. So what I've noticed in
my now almost six years of sitting in this
chair, and it's not just this administration, but it's past administrations
that we talk about deferred maintenance,
and where we are with deferred maintenance, and we're looking at a
deferred maintenance bill of $594,000,000.
And that's huge.
And the only sector we can compare ourselves with
is the private sector. And the private sector tells us the
city should be given or putting X amount of money into capital
improvement and X amount of millions of dollars into
maintenance and operations. We receive less
than half of what they say we should, but we
do it what we can. But the funding
is needed. Being a retired policeman,
I tell Chief Fender I'm 100%, if you cut me,
I still bleed blue. And I tell Chief Pina wait a minute, it'll turn red.
And I understand those
ladies and gentlemen, the job they do, not many people do it,
and they deserve what you give them. But we can't forget about the facilities they
have to work in.
Our biggest fear this year with the, as I
mentioned earlier about shipments being delayed is that we have
HVAC systems that fail,
that cannot be fixed and have to be replaced.
And then there's an eight to twelve week lead time
to get that equipment here. And then we have to rent temporary equipment.
Well, what we found is when we rent that temporary equipment for three or
four months, we could have bought two units that we're
replacing. So that's what hamstrings
us.
Thank you. I neglected to welcome council
member Mary NAN Hoffman, council member Robert Gallegos, and council member
David Robinson. They are here at the Horseshoe. Next question
comes from council member David Robinson and council member Tiffany D
Thomas.
Thank you, Council Member Robinson.
Thank you Chair. Thank you all for your presentation. And I
know the GSD is doing everything you can with
the delays, director, as you mentioned, with the global supply chain,
material shortages, construction schedules, cost inflation,
and the list goes on. I guess there's a bit of a
preview. I know coming up on a TTI committee meeting ahead is
some review of our deferred maintenance on some of
our facilities that are in your portfolio. So this is essentially extra
budgetary question, but something that
I'd like maybe some comment from you about the overall
impact of the delay in the global
supply set of conditions with
what we've been able to do. How you've been able to prioritize
the projects you have and what consequences
we as a city may be suffering in terms of a delay
on prioritized projects that you've had.
Some of us have had in our hoped
for list of priorities for your department and the city.
So there was a time here at City Hall
in the recent past where we had air handler units on
the corner of Walker and Bagby because we had an air
handler unit in the basement fail, and we
were given some serious lead time and
we have to think outside the box. Being former
military, I tell my guys, just because a
company says this, they're not the only people
in the United States that make this stuff. We have to go
elsewhere. We have to use whatever we can to speed the
process up. We've been lucky so far that
most of the lead times we've been given,
we've been able to reduce by looking
elsewhere.
The impact to the city that this will
have if we meet run into these
long delays is we pay extra to
keep a building cool or warm. That's going to be our biggest
problem, is HVAC system failure.
We had an FCA done, as you know, in 2012,
which is outdated, and we have a current one that should be wrapped
up hopefully next month. That's going to give us a new light
on where our facilities stand.
Unfortunately, it's not any better than it was in 2012.
It's a lot worse. Let me say I appreciate that
last comment, especially about HVAC and some of what our buildings need
to do for an upgrade. It's also, in addition to
the costliness of it for our budget, it's also incredibly
expensive from an environmental standpoint. What we're doing to
not upgrade our facilities is one of the biggest
degrees in which we're falling short of some of our climate action goals
and goals to align ourselves with the resilient.
Houston. True. That's one reason why I
went to the administration, asked to start
an energy efficiency section in GSD,
which is one person now, Shelley Carter, who's done an outstanding
job with the I think you're aware of the
CICO loan and the Seco project that we
about to kick off, which is the low hanging fruit of
Led lighting in five facilities to
start. I'll say start to meet those requirements.
Thank you, Chair, and I know we'll get an update of that at the upcoming
TTI committee meeting. So thanks for the view. Thank you,
Council Member Robert Gallegos.
Thank you, Chair, and thank you, Director, for the presentation. I know
I'm on my 9th year here on Council, and every year I do look
at the demographic breakdown of the different departments.
I'd like to give you kudos in regards to
the breakdown here on employees in
the department. It reflects our city.
But I would also ask if you can give me a breakdown on the
management of your department as well.
I'd like to review that if at all possible.
Okay. Thank you. Council Member Ed Pollard.
Thank you, Chair, and good morning to everyone. Director, thank you for your presentation.
Thank you to your entire team for all the work that you do.
If you had to put a dollar amount, let's say we could use some ARPA
dollars to go towards deferred maintenance and things that
would dramatically improve the state of our buildings and maintenance,
what would that dollar amount be? A reasonable number.
You said dramatically improve.
Yeah, to dramatically improve.
I'll meet you halfway. 250,000,000.
Thank you. Thank you. There are
no other council members in queue. I have one comment and then a
question. There is no department in the city of Houston
that I interact with and probably many council members interact with
on a daily basis. Your department is phenomenal. And I know a
lot of this is under my friend Eric Alexander,
but the janitors that we have that do the hard work day
in and day out are always there with a smile and
a can do spirit. I miss miss Anna. Can you get it back across
the street? Because I love asking her about her dad and seeing how
he's doing. And John just does a great job.
And I remember when Neil was a security guard
and we hired him at GSD. Neil was the most respectful is the
most respectful. Yes, sir. No, sir, can do. Guy I've ever
met. Positive spirit, works his butt
off. He just exemplifies the employees
that we have in the city of Houston.
And there's a famous saying,
fish rots from the head. So when there's a good head, the rest
of the employees will do a good job. And it's because of the executive
staff I'm looking at here. And thanks for doing everything
and doing the hard work. Those people are a joy
to be around. They make my life better today. It makes
me realize how lucky that I am,
personally. And just kudos to the people that
you have in your area that do the tough jobs day in and day
out. I know it's not a sexy job, but, God,
they do fantastic work. So thanks for those folks.
My question is wrapped around deferred maintenance. What is
our deferred maintenance backlog? Now, I know we did that study a while
back. What is the dollar amount? I know you gave a $250,000,000.
Say that again. 594,000,000. Say that again.
594,000,000.
It will increase. The estimate is in
2024. It'll stay pretty flat for next year or two,
but 2024, it will go up to 600 million plus.
So when you look at deferred maintenance, that's a lot of money to put into
it. Seems like every day we have people working on our elevators.
But think big or go
home. And I look at the land that we have that isn't in
much use next door to us. Tranquility park. Is it
a good park? Yeah, it's okay. It's not one of the better ones.
I'd love to see us build a new facility over there. Blow up.
Lanier, the building. That's a horrible building.
Horrible this building has its issues,
but it's an art deco building and it probably has a great historical
meaning to it. But the police building now, the horrible building.
I know we looked at something. The old exxon building.
God, this is probably five, six years ago.
Can the record reflect that the chair has appreciated historical
architecture? I'd like to let the chair reflect that
from my architect friend. Thank you. Richard will appreciate that.
But don't you think we need to one day look at a long term
plan and begin that so we get away from this deferred maintenance
and do something with building a new facility, maybe do a three P.
We've had a lot of conversations wrapped around that.
Just your thoughts. You've been around for many years.
There is a plan or there has been talk to
Renovate 611 Walker to do something
to do something different
at Tranquility Park. So there is a plan.
It's in the rough stages, but there's talk about doing
exactly that. So do you think it's an optimistic
plan or a realistic or a pessimistic?
No one else is in queue, so I'm going to do you think
we'll get it done because our deferred
maintenance gets bigger and bigger and bigger. That's a tough one because
the deferred maintenance is going to keep climbing, unfortunately,
and the prices are going to keep going up. So I
would be on the pessimistic side. Pessimistic. Okay, well,
we'll go to public speakers, but I always sort of kid mayor Turner,
I said we have a year and a half. What is your legacy?
Complete communities, things like that. I'd love to see the
Sylvester turn of building right across the street from us, housing a
lot of people that need a new place to be housed. So I'll
keep after them as long as you keep after them. Okay. Because I think there
is a plan. Council member Gallegos thank you, chair. Actually, there is a
master plan for Tranquility Park at the parks department.
Unfortunately, there's no monies for this master plan.
But that was something that I had seen way back when former
director Turner was the parks director.
And it's a really nice plan.
Unfortunately, there's no monies. But I do agree with you in regards to
the fountains as they're at Tranquility Park, I understand we're going to be
trying to repair those once again, but in
my opinion, I think that's just a lot of money being wasted because they've tried
fixing that several times and they just keep breaking.
So hopefully we can come up with the master plan or
something that will save the city money instead of using it to
repair something that constantly keeps breaking. Thank you. Thank you,
council member. So before we go to public speakers,
yesterday, we let public speaking get a little bit away
from us. We'd like all the questions to be directed to council members. We'll do
the best to try and answer them if we need some input from staff,
we'll do that. But we want the directors
to be focused on council members and public speakers to
be focused on us as well. So with that being
said, I will ask you to exit stage Bright and
we will call on our first public speaker and that is Sabah
Blanding. And if I can add one thing, GSD,
we are looking outside of the box for funding.
We're actually meeting with Bill Kelly and his staff to see
if we can tap into some of the biden infrastructure bill
funding towards energy efficiency.
Just wanted to leave that.
Thank you. And Ms. Blanding, direct the questions to us and we
will field the questions from here. Okay. Good morning.
My name is Saba Blanding. I'm a resident of
District I, so council member Gallegos's district.
My question is what environmental services and
asbestos, lead, mold, soil remediation
are you able to accomplish on your current budget? 17 million seems fairly
low for such an essential safety work for property and environmental management.
What are the comprehensive needs of the city of Houston? What resources
would this department need to expand to address the full
needs of the city? And what are efforts to make sure these services
are addressed equitably across the city of Houston?
We just talked about deferred maintenance a minute ago.
You heard it heavy. Bill on deferred maintenance.
Keeping a building like this up to speed with environmental
friendly issues is really a tough task.
I think the direction that we should head would be to build a
lead platinum type facility that
has all the things that you would want from an environmental standpoint and
then house various departments. We tried to do that a couple of
years ago when we were in negotiations with the folks
who owned the old Exxon building down the street. But we had
a number of issues with it because of the access
to it underground and having the tunnel system work.
But we don't do a very good job with
the environmental side because of the age of the buildings and the condition of
the buildings. But we should do better. And I think that will come
with our ability to possibly do what
council member Gallegos was talking about and that is to do a
new development that will house various departments within the city.
I don't know if any other council members have any. I'll defer
to my Black Cape architect,
David Robinson, who's in queue right now. Well, I think
you're right. I think there's just lots to be done with our
existing facilities, which is why I wanted to mention to the director some
of those important aspects of deferred maintenance. But I think
this Blanding raises an important point, not only for the
issues already discussed with the cost of the mechanical systems,
the upgrade and the cost of the environment, but also just the
health impacts of all the users.
So those are concerns that layer into how
I believe we should prioritize the facilities and think
about that carefully before we embark on any new programs and
new construction. But I share your feeling, Chair, about Tranquility
Park, and I know there are some plans that are coming forward. I believe the
mayor's got a few on his desk that he's considering about that right now.
That's great. Thank you. Thank you, Ms. Blinding. Next was Jason
Oliver. I don't see Jason today, so we're missing him.
What's that? He's running a little late. He's running late.
That's all right. Lauren Johnson.
Good morning, Ms. Johnson. Hi. Good morning.
My name is Lauren Johnson, and I wanted to ask which specific entities
are receiving the $29 million from the Chapter 380
agreement and how much each of them are receiving and
how do those get approved? Is it city council that approves those?
Yes, it runs through the Office of Economic Development.
380 agreements are reimbursements for infrastructure work
that the City of Houston does not is not
responsible for within certain developments. And that 380 goes back towards
paying those developments for infrastructure work that should have been taken on by the
City of Houston. I'm sorry.
Go ahead and
debt service. So, like yesterday, we went through our Houston Public Works
presentation. And in that presentation, you can see there's a dotted line
around 380 that also goes back to paying our debt. So our
pay as you go programs and all of our infrastructure programs. So those
are all reimbursements. Correct. Okay. Correct.
And many times the developers don't get to a point where we reimburse
them a penny. And we have many developers like that, but we reimburse
them over a period of time instead of taking the work at
that point in time and spending the monies upfront. So it's
actually a pretty good program that works to our advantage. Any other
council member questions, answers on that? Okay, thank you.
Ms. Johnson. Ms.
Jill Grochell. Good to see you again this morning.
Appreciate you all being here again. On second day,
actually, third day.
Thank you for the welcome back. Yes, ma'am. Good morning to you all. I will
say I'm a little disappointed that you
asked the people that gave the budget to walk out
yesterday. It was great to be able to speak with them and
let them know how much we like what they do, and we're proud of what
they do. And so I'm sad to see them leave.
Yesterday, we heard a community group speak about the needs to address the
exposed drainage impacting their community in the north
side of Houston, the northeast side of Houston. Excuse me.
They were directed. That might be a CIP issue.
What can we do to prioritize these important projects within
that department? Thank you for the question. Council member Abby Cayman.
Just as some background, I know I can only speak to our
committee, but we had been asked as standard procedure
for all. Committees when the directors, after they present,
sometimes public comment, can go on for an extended period
of time and they all need to go back to work.
So I appreciate what you're saying, I just also
want to provide context that it's more so the general rule
for all committees, it's not the exception during the budgetary process.
Understood. So to answer your question,
CIP is a roll in three year process.
So every project we had in fiscal year 22
should be completed and rolls off. Generally not the case because we have
more projects than available funding. And then 23 rolls
on and then we add on the backside, it'd be fiscal
year 27. So we go fiscal year 23 to 27.
So then when we finish the ones on 23, they roll off and we add
28 on board. So the tough
thing about that is that many of us are on here for
just another year and a half and we won't see the work of
our office staff. And what we did
in the CIP, that's going to come up long after we are here
or we disappear. So it seems
to work, but the problem we always have is it's underfunded
and we never do all of the projects. That was one of the
reasons why about six years ago we put in the council district service fund.
So each of us have an allocation of dollars that we can use towards
projects that we think are emergency type projects.
And we all do a really good job of identifying the projects
within our area. We firmly believe nobody knows our
district better than ourselves because we're in them
every day. And I include the at larges as well. I know I
joke around a lot, a little bit tough on you, but you all are always
present at our meetings and always concerned about our
area. But CIP is a tough one because it's
underfunded and we have too many needs and wants to really fully fund
it. But working through council district service funds.
And now with the SWAT program, we have extra millions going
in that and maybe we'll have a different allocation when
we look towards I believe if this budget is based on
no increase on sales tax revenue,
I think we're going to have a significant increase in sales tax revenue because
it's predicated upon the price of goods today. And everybody who's been
in a grocery store or bought anything knows that the price continues to
go up. Thus, unfortunately, our sales tax revenue goes up.
So I think we'll have the ability to create more in fund balance and maybe
use some of that fund balance for exactly what we talked about.
Just real quick, do you believe that the Northeast project
is an emergency? Could that go into the emergency bucket?
So I'll leave that up to council member Jackson to decide what's an emergency
in her area not. But I live in Kingwood and
I've been in District B more times than I've been anywhere because it's
near my house. I go up there quite often. But I
looked at those photos again this morning. It was concerning.
But then again, my area lost 5000 homes
and 500 businesses due to flooding.
And we're trying to make sure that when the next hurricane comes,
we don't get caught in that floodwater again. So we all have those fears.
I'm sure that Council Member Amy Peck will say
the same thing about her district, but Council Member
Abby Cayman, especially Myerland and what we've had to do
there. When you live at or
just a little bit above sea level, you're going to have those types
of situations pop up. And I don't care what you call it,
whether you call it global change or global warming,
the tornadoes are coming more rapidly and the hurricanes have more force
to them. So we'll see. Council member Tiffany Thomas.
Thank you. And thank you for participating in public comments.
Really helpful feedback, but just something to consider.
Imagine who we could be as a city if we actually receive flooding dollars
from the Glo, right? Imagine the projects that
have been in queue for cycles that are scheduled but not funded.
Imagine who we could be if the federal infrastructure funds were a
direct allocation to the city versus an application process.
Because if it had not been for Hurricane Harvey in this region,
those dollars wouldn't be available. Right? And so we are missing
out on that. And then working through the federal process to
schedule priority projects in any neighborhood. They're all priority.
Right? Let me say, I am one of those people that I lost
my home during Harvey and so I get it. But I also know
how privileged I am and that we were okay. And I believe
that there were many others that weren't. And that's where my heart
goes. Sure. But here's my point is that we are limited
while also being constrained. We're constrained because we don't
have the support, the funding from the state.
We're working through the process federally. And so what we have as a local
city, we're doing the very best and it's not as fast as we
would like. I have at least five unscheduled funded
projects that have been on the books for a while. So I mean, you're absolutely
correct. But just for the public that's listening.
The larger issue is that Houston has been missing out and
we have a serious issue around flooding and infrastructure because
it's not a matter of if another storm will come, it's when.
And it could rain for 30 minutes in the city and you have two inches
of water in your drain, like those storms are that intense. And so we
are trying to keep up with that. And then also look at the plans
that were designed pre Harvey or right after Harvey.
Now looking at our new resiliency standards. Now looking at the new
data and city modeling and what does it take in terms of drainage.
So there's some work we have to do to make sure that those plans meet
those standards, because we don't want to offer your neighborhood or any neighborhood
a project just to say we did a project. We want to make sure that
when we come in and offer a project that you feel safe knowing that those
drains work, those streets will clear and that you won't be in a danger
of losing your home. And so we have to continue this process
of raising this issue. And thank you for bringing
that information to us and keeping it on our radar. It's very helpful.
Thank you. Council member Tasha Jackson. Thank you,
Mayor Pro TEM, and thank you, Council Member Thomas for that.
Also, as Council Member Thomas said, we have SWAT projects,
but then also we have to think about the revenue cap.
I'm hearing throughout the whole from yesterday, the issue is
money. Where are we getting the money? And what we're talking about right now is
the revenue that the city have, but there is revenue that we could
have that we don't have because of a revenue cap. And so
two caps. Yeah. Even if we just had gotten
rid of the city cap, we would have more resources to do a lot of
these projects. So the flood mitigation projects, we have 14
projects on the book for District B and working
with Harris County Flood Control to kind of mitigate some of these projects. So projects
are moving forward. It's not moving fast enough. We have some projects
on the books from 2011.
These are capital improvement projects. So just know that
we need dollars, and the dollars is out there,
but we just need to identify ways to get it. And removing
that revenue cap is one of the ways that we can get some dollars to
do projects that we definitely need within our neighborhood.
So thank you. Thank you for participating, and thanks again, Ms. Grochell. You're welcome.
I see Mr. Oliver showed up, so if you present your tardy
slip to the principal, we'll allow you. You have
your 1 minute. Good to see you again.
Good morning. Yeah, still morning.
Okay. Been here for a while,
so good morning, everyone.
Let's see. So I just came
in and I talked about this a bit yesterday, but I think it falls
specifically under General Services. So the security
right. I tried to use my Harris County enhanced library card
ID to get in, and they told me that I needed either a state
ID or driver's license or passport to get in.
Again, this is something we live in Houston. We have quite a
few people who may not have those forms of ID.
So thinking about who is able to come in here and provide public
comment, somebody behind me yesterday had forgotten his
license and was having trouble getting in a staffer once a
Council Member Jackson staffers had to come down and vouch for him.
Right. So we really
need to kind of make sure that this is more accessible in that way.
I forgot my other thing. Capital improvement
projects. I just think translation is a
big deal, especially for city documents, thinking about how can we improve
the infrastructure on budgetary documents and
then capital improvement documents, because these affect the entire city.
So I just want to make sure and kind of urge that as well.
Sure. Council member Robert Gallegos. Thank you,
Chair. Thank you for that explanation. When you were saying
that you tried to get in with the new Harris County ID,
they didn't accept it. No, I tried it yesterday on the first
floor and then today in the basement. I'm glad
you brought that to my attention because I've met with Mayor Turner
to see if we will accept the
new Harris County ID. And I think that would be a great,
great asset, hopefully.
Can you tell me if that ID has a chip on it?
I don't think it has a chip. Yeah, it just has
the card and then photo address
and then gender and right. Because I know the
sheriff's department accepts it. I know Mayor Turner is looking at HPD
to see if HPD will accept it. And I'm hoping
that this is something that can be used for metro,
something that can be used for the B cycle stations.
Basically a universal Harris County ID that Harris
County residents can use. So thank you for bringing that to my attention.
I'm hoping the mayor's administration is listening to this as well.
Thank you. Thank you. Council Member Abby Cayman I also
wanted to echo my appreciation for flagging the issue and Council Member Gallegos
for the update and taking the charge, especially given
the implementation of the state's photo ID laws,
the additional hurdles that go into place right. That make it that much
harder for an average person to get that state
issued driver's license or photo ID will be
critical to make sure that we're being as inclusive as possible within the parameters
of security and safety that we have to provide at the city.
Right. Thank you. Council member Robert Gallegos.
Thank you, council Member Kayman. Yes. This is an ID that I think can be
used for homeless individuals that need an ID
for individuals that are coming out of jail that
don't have an ID. So that way, hopefully, they can find a job and
what have you. So this is something that I'm hoping
we can work with the Harris County and have it as a
universal ID for Harris County residents or who lose them
in floods that are so rare in Houston and Harris
County. Right, right. Thank you, Ronnie. On that
note, this concludes our General Service Department budget
workshop. We will now transition to to Parks
and Recreation. I see those folks are here so we'll
allow a couple of minute transition and we'll get right
into it a little bit early, which we couldn't say at all yesterday.